out of florida which is reporting one in
five
of the nation's new covid cases only
48 percent of the state's population has
gotten both shots
and amid the spread of misinformation
this is slightly below the national
average on vaccinations
manuel bajorquez joins us from
jacksonville manny good morning
good morning anthony let me give you
some perspective here at one point last
month the university of florida health
system in jacksonville
had only 14 covid positive patients
now there are 178 more than 90
of them are unvaccinated for the staff
here it's not necessarily reliving the
worst of the pandemic
because this is the highest number of
covet 19 patients they have seen
since it started remember why
we have been together for
31 years 62 year old curtis sanderlin
recently lost his wife joy to covet 19.
now he's fighting for his life at this
jacksonville hospital
how are you feeling right right now as
far as your
ability to breathe and what this virus
has done to you it goes
the breathing my breathing goes
it comes and goes but the grief remains
sanderlin who struggled to get through
the interview is not vaccinated
but interestingly neither are about half
of the staff at the health system
where he's being treated says chad
nielsen director of infection prevention
at the university of florida health
jacksonville people frequently ask
why aren't more of your staff
vaccinating we say well they're still
part of the general population
they consume the same news they consume
the same social media as others and
they're just as susceptible to some of
the
misinformation and things like that in
the community yes the unvaccinated
are in kovitz crosshairs but the impacts
can reach
beyond it's been said this is a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
but if all of your rooms are full and
you can't get other patients in here for
procedures that affects everybody
absolutely our hospital is filling with
a lot of unvaccinated covid patients
and what's going to happen is is it's
going to keep other patients from
receiving care
many who end up at the hospital regret
not getting the shot
says nurse zoe sinis we have a patient
today that
says that he would like to get the
vaccine now as for curtis sanderland
given what you've gone through would you
get the vaccine now
yes sir you would get it now no doubt
about it
what's your message for people who
haven't gotten it yet
take it take it
take it do the right thing
doctors here fear they that they may not
see the peak of this surge
until september last month when the
state's positivity rate for
new cases fell below five percent the
state of florida stopped issuing daily
reports of cases and deaths instead
going to weekly ones
but now with that positivity rate at 15
percent
some critics say those daily reports
need to come back to help better track
the spread eureka all right manny thank
you